okay yeah there's no bed welcome to this
video yeah let's play our kiddos um okay
play with a place t5 and they usually
try to bore me to death in verse III and
Bishop f4 okay let players reversed
ready Oh early a 3x1 sorry okay that's
really early hmm i don't know it's a
hello it's a big deal that he got to
sell usually why doesn't manage this but
yeah what about this pawn said a
weakness is it a strength I think I'm
not unhappy him let's see probably
roughly equal this position I'm not
saying I'm better but ok so he likes to
put put it on d5 that's understandable
and probably something I should not have
allowed all that easily okay but I can
play here and then 927 yeah let's put it
on sit seven please might be five is
really annoying so I'd like to prevent
that and I'm also checking a six I mean
maybe I just get the pawn well the big
name you've had to think that I get the
pawn but I actually do get the pawn
light bill 570 is that dangerous it
doesn't look dangerous I can just go
queen-to-be 7i believe okay the tears I
mean d 5 is opening up my diagonal and
killing as Bishop so that's a good
position really I've gotta be honest I
always like to beat those people who
play C 3 in this position it's just such
a such a lame move instead of playing d5
and have an interesting position where
you have really realistic hopes of being
better playing c3 is just wrong ok so
I'm going to try to attack his center
him let's see um yeah twin Hanks I
cannot take but you could be eight
prolly not so bad
just not so sure what why should do him
cannot go e five at least I don't think
it's easy to do my idea is just to take
and play something like we need to be
three just probably put enough pressure
on the beep on to win it ultimately okay
yeah just take it is one nothing
particularly wrong with 85 either yeah
but ok then I keep it simple this is
really the keep it simple attitude
usually serves me all right ok 9 a-5
unfortunately this is something I did
not really see before beforehand ha
that's bad
oh man it that was really impress eyes
what I did allowing him into into this
okay I can't play 85 I probably have to
do that Luke takes rook takes my eggs I
take on be 2nite takes i play with a 74
pins oh yeah but that did not anticipate
this yeah this is probably very okay and
you can only attack e 7 with something
like Knight to c6 but look x f king at
eight is a very simple reply okay so i
think i go here just make sure that this
pawn structure is frozen and i have king
at seven as an easy move against Knight
to c6 30 I know I actually play this
yeah there is a typical idea I'm the
mining d5 however oh i just got 93 m ok
so I rather take this then I wasn't
ideal but ok it's so good I'm a pawn up
and I have a strong center but didn't
really see that 93 were so good after
stop overlooking things ok then if I
will look more stuff it could still be
tricky let's see ok
take a form they trade trade one night
okay tonight is good 95 but I have to
get my pawns going at some at some point
just wonder how exactly to do that maybe
this and then some each five yeah okay
let it's also find now okay night before
it's not clear that this helps maybe
just bring this up fine morning I would
like to play back into this I can do
this just 44 took me a moment to can
realize that sorry
expected to move the dishes the end he
does
so the deep horn should go should run
not sure if i were to put the king for
that but this looks more cover CD 191
i'm not quite sure what the point of
that one yeah maybe c3 immediately was
better even but thanks go three only
okay so that was a really nice position
out of the out of the opening that I got
let's flick on the analysis and have a
look yes yeah I'm always happy to beat
bitter sea three guys he would simply
like why not do this it's good ok c 3
and well be six is actually a slightly
risky move but most people playing c3
are not interested in interesting games
you can do this now which is actually
good for white but it's yeah taking a
risk here and they usually just play the
same move anyway this was interesting
though with 8.5 i don't think it leads
to all that much but it's a little
interesting yeah i don't i don't
actually think that a 6 can be the way
to do it in anything you should maybe
try to take off these six in some way
and try to play against the b6 pawn you
can also unlike wind weight with this
and only later decide yeah well i don't
think that this is this is leading to
all that much quinces 7 capsule cream 6
195
damn PL definitely okay but I mean it
was completely um please unnecessary to
give the pawn I believe this is just I
think it just landed it I'm just a poor
now for absolutely nothing yeah I'm
pretty happy up to this point maybe yeah
a 5s the engine indicates if indeed
stronger just go for that yeah I didn't
I didn't really see the issue here with
9 a-5 but I think that was a good
solution I'm intending to go 8-4 and
this is what he did light a 5 rupee I
wanted to do actually okay now of course
I can't just take I didn't really see
that this is a stronger and the way the
way it happened there's this end game
this is the winning ending with good
technical play I made a mistake though I
probably should play at 5pm in layers
yeah and here this is a bit too quick to
smooth many I don't know it is good
anyway and for I should probably prepare
it but ok the engine actually wants to
play it and no in fact not this but this
but what about this move 9f 69 f5 let's
see you hon yeah ok yeah it's a pawn and
I'm just better word I thought I thought
that this wasn't so precise but it is
probably it is probably win if you don't
do anything Italian you good and so I
hope I didn't blunder anything this
doesn't look like it feels like II
didn't even decent enough job him
yeah I'm in the opening he shouldn't
play a sick so I guess ok and then ok 6
was not giving it away porn this is the
key thing like him if you if you play
normal Morsi I used to still should be
ok and rather like here because sorry
the bishop here as a passive piece and
b5 coming and it's just just a bit
passive ok guys thanks for watching